alors c'est vrai que c'est un joueur que
je kiffe et grappins kurt extraordinaire
juste est ce que vous comprenez qu'on
veuille que ce joueur ne soit plus en
équipe de france est ce que vous pensez
il y en a beaucoup qui n'ont plus rien
pour vous c'est muriel physique membres
du parc animalier cbl oui bonsoir en
effet quand on porte le maillot de
l'équipe de france ça veut dire qu'on
incarne la france qu'on incarne ces
valeurs et les valeurs de la france
n'est absolument pas la maltraitance
animale au contraire c'est le respect du
droit de la justice on est dans un état
de droit un état républicain et donc on
ne peut plus enfin il ya beaucoup de
gens sur les réseaux sociaux des deux
cent mille tweets sur twitter de
personnes qui sont unanimement indignés
et de nombreuses personnes réclament que
ce joueur de football ne puisse plus
porter les couleurs de la france alors
qu'après la sanction c'est pas nous qui
allons la prendre mais c'est vrai que
mes commandes sont arrivées ces images
jonathan c'est simplement les dérives de
la surmédiatisation des joueurs de foot
et le manque d'intelligence de la part
de l'entourage des joueurs il fallait
ces internats lui qui le film et que son
frère son frère son frère qui n'a
probablement que des robinets des rues
des robinets de roblès
sait très bien que son frère est une
personne qui est médiatisé qui est un
joueur de foot dans un grand club qui
est un joueur international et s'amuse à
le filmer sur des axes que n'importe qui
jugeraient répréhensible et de le mettre
sur les réseaux sociaux c'est vraiment
d'une débilité son nom et c'est
affligeant franchement je ne comprends
pas comment ça peut arriver à l'esprit
de quelqu'un de faire ça et de ce film
est un problème c'est pas les images en
fait le problème c'est l'effet c'est ce
qui s'est passé et même à la limite
heureusement qu'il ya des images presque
paraître qu'on va pouvoir sortir le chat
de cette situation c'est sûr parce que
là on a un animal qui est sans défense
qui est pris au piège dans un
appartement et qui est 2009
si vite et en fait on va se on va jouer
avec lui comme si c'était un ballon de
foot comme si c'était un objet et puis
là il la personne ça le jour toute bonne
pour le moment et en sauce en situation
d'impunité parce que même si le club
anglais a dit qu'il allait prouver si tu
leur surseoir à laon via une nature ou
s'il est titulaire ce soir à
l'horreur après sérénité c'est le
blizzard est qu après c'est le business
c'est ça c'est ça qu'est vous gilles
verdez nom est honteux c'est
répréhensible c'est lamentable j'espère
qu'il sera condamné parce qu en
angleterre la loi a été durcie risque de
12 mois à cinq ans de prison attention
mais néanmoins néanmoins madame excusez
moi vous comme moi on a commis des
erreurs quand on commet des erreurs on
paie et on nous donne une deuxième
chance voulait rayer ce joueur qui est
jeune oui de la carte
je lis juste ma mère fois qu'il aura
payé qu'il aura été condamné j'espère
qu'il le sera mais il s'est excusé ça ne
suffit pas j'ose espérer que c'est un
geste exceptionnel qu'il a commis
d'accord mais néanmoins vous pouvez pas
briser sa carrière pour ce geste non
nous allons suis
allé après endroits comme vient de le
dire je suis pas juge donc c'est pas moi
qui vais décider de la sanction
seulement cette personne est un exemple
et un modèle pour de nombreux enfants
donc il faut qu'il y ait une sanction
que ce soit également exemplaire qu'on
sait très bien que sur les réseaux
sociaux il ya beaucoup de gens qui vont
partir dans la surenchère dans le défi à
la maltraitance et qui va faire les
chemins avoir autant je suis je suis
scandalisé par la part pas parler les
gestes les amis appellent à brigitte
bardot j'ai même le nom de mon chat
tatoué sur le corps un travail plus
s'appelle marcel c'est pas génial cole
mais ceci étant dit
du moment où nous vivons dans une
société où le joueur de foot doit être
un exemple c'est que quelque chose ne
tourner pas rond khartoum a fait quelque
chose de totalement répréhensible pour
moi c'est aussi grave que s'il avait
tapé leur enfant qui est dans la vidéo
que s'il avait tapé sa compagne les
animaux sont des êtres du mandat sur
sensibilité c'est vraiment atroce de
voir ces images surtout en boucle comme
ça mais à quel moment on doit imputé un
footballeur à devoir de responsabilité
pour moi je sais que c'est bien la bière
bon sens et de dire ça c'est de dire les
joueurs de foot ont des exemples etc
mais posons nous les bonnes questions si
on est dans une société où c'est un
joueur de foot qui a fait toute sa quête
tout ça toute son enfance et son
adolescence dans un enfant au centre de
formation qui n'a pas fait de très
grandes études ça être un exemple de
moralité et de bon comportement pour nos
enfants c'est que d'une part l'école va
pas bien et que les parents font pas
leur vélo nature relents fontaine vous
souhaitez acheter scandalisée par ce que
je vois et je dis oui bien sûr pas voilà
je pense que des trucs que tu fais pas
il s'excuse mais moi je ne sais pas
c'est que ce que je peux lui de ses
explications qu'est ce qui fait qu
devant tes gosses tu me maltraites un
chat rival de compagnie fin des excuses
je rappelle dû faire ça toi donc ça pas
de sens oui je pense qu'il faut le gérer
l'équipe de foot devant le gabon la
partie symbole est pardon pardon mais tu
fais un peu le tt dans le foot tu dis
est une société c'est assez de cutter et
quelques vitres on sait que les fonds
sont une forte image à moi je suis
désolé le jour j'aurai des enfants 6
janvier si j'en suis au point de dire
même et à mes gamins de prendre pour
exemple de moralité
ya des joueurs de foot les comportements
oui et qui sont des experts oui voilà
antoine griezmann j'en ai plein ap
kilian
karim moi j'aurai encore karim maddi aux
assises d'horizon on est surtout
contents car ils mettent des maillets
qui sont généraux qui a dit toi tu
noteras que
ça me rend folle ça me rend folle et moi
je pense que cette personne le belge
d'aller jouer au foot et de faire son
travail il ferait mieux d'aller se faire
soigner psychologiquement parce que pour
moi quelqu'un qui fait ça
et après peut-être que s'il est guéri et
qui voit des psychologues wallace dans
ces cas là on leur donne son travail on
lui redonne sa vie mais là pour moi
c'est pas normal de voir des choses
comme ça annoncé qu'il aima reste un
enfant à reserrer les généralement des
grands tueurs en série je vais faire un
show énorme comment toujours par les
animaux et non
celle là tu vas loin
alors lisez des bouquins je voulais dit
je traduis d'état depuis bogota comme
français mais pas mais c'est un
comportement psychologique qui est
dangereux attention n'allez pas plus
loin mais j'ai dit passionné quand on
voit ce qui m'énerve c'est que j'ai
l'impression qu'on lira cheese un peu la
violence gym tout à l'heure a dit on a
tous commis des erreurs dans notre
jeunesse c'est pas une petite erreur de
jeunesse de faire ça en parle
à l'audience le coeur du débat c'est
qu'il faut la condamner davantage s'il
avait commis d'autres actes qui sont
aussi répréhensible il aurait été
écartée que son club immédiatement là
c'est pas le cas parce que quelque part
on dit pas mais on sous-entend c'est pas
très grave de maltraiter un chamassy
c'est extrêmement grave il faut le
condamner il faut qu'ils soient
suspendus l'équipe de france répond non
c'est il faut qu'ils aient des grosses
sanctions il faut qu'il faut que tu dis
donc quand même moi je dis non mais gino
quand même parce qu'on peut pas arrêter
la galère du mec il ya des offres on a
vu des joueurs de foot n'ont même pas
oui mais je suis un footeux mais je suis
par exemple jonathan je suis pas
d'accord avec ce qu'ils disent sur
l'image que ça renvoie le football il ya
justement un exemple qui doivent montrer
l'exemple c'est qu'ils tuent et jonathan
tu parles de société il ya qu à voir
quand l'équipe de france égalé au avant
sa dette ou le monde descendent et sur
les champs elysées c'est panacée pas
anodin ça quel que soit l'éducation d'où
vient le mec moi je pense qu'il doit
être sanctionné lourdement et qu'on doit
savoir la sanction qu'il a eue parce que
tu t'amuses pas à valence est un chat
comme ça n'importe où surtout devant ton
enfant après tu peux paraître c'est une
surenchère sur les réseaux sociaux les
gens vont dire le zoom à challenges pas
ça me fait de la peine parce que je le
suivais depuis saint-etienne janot bien
j'adore ce joueur royal est sûre il
avait très grosse blessure et ça il
mettra un terme à sa carrière il est
revenu il est revenu en force et quand
j'ai vu ça je me suis dit le mec prend
des bars et bars je vais ramener à la
vie un jour il prend des bars et des
bars il est heureux il franchit pas
combien par mois par rapport à un par
semaine riche en ouest à parme par
semaine il doit prendre est le mec il
n'arrive pas qui fait ils arrivent quand
même à être méchant pour moi je vais
dire pour moi il a fait un truc de
connard au moins il a fait un connard en
faisant ça ces enfants du coup qu'est ce
qu'est ce qu'on fait de certains joueurs
d'où jérôme boateng quand même pas le
citer qui a été condamné lance conjugale
et violence sont légales qui joue
titulaire alors appuyé cheveux mais
géraldine à raison qu'est ce qu'on fait
alors ce cas là c'est ça en fait que
manger des masses et de paris la fin
d'année il a été condamné la peine donc
c'est ça qu'il faut qu'ils payent fossés
sont notamment pour compagne
l'association en train d après il ya une
association parce qu'il a les moyens et
surtout faire l'écho de cette grosse
amende et dire regardez ce que parce que
ça peut vous coûter de faire ça en
france c'est parce sa cascade en chasse
à l'ours adet c'est un être humain
scheidt tu t'amuses pas à mettre des
coups de pieds comme ça sur un chat si
vous dis je vous le dis aux gens très
vivement n'est pas d'animaux soul et si
vous aimez pas ça si vous inventer une
vie en danger par un chien je prends
d'achat si vous n'avez pas les couilles
d'avoir des animaux ne prenait pas
d'animaux les animaux ils vont faire
sans vous inquiétez pas si c'est pour
vous défouler sur des chaussures des
chiens vous êtes des grosses merdes ne
prenait pas d'animaux c'est pas la peine
[Applaudissements]